welcome
everybody today we have the pleasure of
uh having dr paula
lopez pena who is a postdoc
with us in the refugee program here at
yale
uh presenting her work
on the causes and consequences of ethnic
violence in
myanmar dr lopez
pena has
been teaching here at the department of
economics and her areas of research are
applied microeconomics and development
economics
she studies how non-cognitive
skills and adverse life events affect
health and labor market
outcomes her current projects focus on
entrepreneurship
firm productivity and the causes and
consequences
of violence so thank you very much paula
and the floor is yours
uh thank you very much teresta for the
introduction and also for
hosting this event we are delighted to
be presenting our work on the causes and
consequences
of ethnic violence in myanmar today and
here the caveat is today we're
going to be presenting results from the
decade prior to the beginning of the
pandemic
my co-authors are here with me today
austin davis from american university
mushvik mubarak from yale and jayawan
from the harvard business schools and
we're all looking forward to having your
feedback and comments
feel free to ask me questions directly
at any time
just unmute yourself or if you prefer
you can
just write your question on the chat box
and one of us will
answer your question as soon as possible
and with that i'm gonna get started and
i
want to start by briefly
introducing the context for the
persecution of rohingya muslims
in myanmar as many of you may know
myanmar
is one of the most ethnically diverse
countries on earth and almost since its
foundation
it has been torn apart by arm clashes
between the
different ethnic militias and the
state's arms forces
the tatmudu and of all ethnic groups
the rohingya muslims stood out for
having been the most
severely persecuted minority
they were stripped of citizenship in
1982
and ever since then they have been
relentlessly harassed
both by the tarnado and sometimes by
their own neighbors next door
furthermore there is growing evidence
that there has been a sharp increase
in the number of violent events
targeting rohingya muslims
since 2011 which was the year in which
myanmar started as a country a
transition into democracy
the latest outbreak of violence the
infamous military crackdown
that took place in 2017 alone
displays over 700 000 rohingya muslims
the vast majority of whom are currently
living in bangladesh
in crowded refugee camps and one of the
things that one of the facts that we're
going to present to you today
is that very large proportions of this
refugee of the refugees living in cox's
bazar
is that the vast majority of them report
having survived
or witnessed physical assault murder
rape and arson attacks
and despite how pervasive these
narratives are
what happened exactly in the aftermath
of the 2017 crackdown and why it
happened
remains highly contested and our paper
will speak directly to the two
predominant
narratives and explanations for what
happened and why
the first is that of the international
community
which primarily agrees that the kind of
violence
that the rohingya have been exposed to
especially during and after 2017
are a textbook example of ethnic
cleansing
and that the evidence of mass killings
and mass
gun graves that they have been exposed
to show a clear
genocidal intent on the side of the
military
on the other hand the competing
narrative is that of the
former civilian government of myanmar
now the polls
former state counselor ansan suchi
declared that it was still not easy to
establish
clear patterns on it of events and that
it's possible that some refugees might
have
provided inaccurate or exaggerated
information
so the bottom line is the government of
myanmar
argues that there is no evidence that
the persecution of rohingya muslims or
violence against rohingya muslims
has been widespread or systematic
our goal with this paper is to provide
quantitative evidence
to complement the existing qualitative
narratives
those that have been told by refugees
themselves
and reported by numerous journalistic
accounts from reporters in the field
and the two main contributions that this
paper makes
is on the one hand we're gonna exploit a
very digital data set
that contains daily data on conflict
events from across myanmar
for over a decade and this makes our
conclusions
less susceptible to cherry-picking and
less susceptible to perhaps
over-relying on arguably inaccurate
recollections and in doing so what we
hope is to provide
a descriptive in-depth um
set of facts indicative of a long-term
methodical pattern on the side of the
military
and how the military treats differently
rohingya from other ethnic minorities
and importantly our data will allow us
to tell you
a causal story on one important driver
of violence and our focus here is going
to be
that violence has economic motivations
and this side of the story has often
been overlooked
develop in many instances the conflict
has been characterized
as being underlined by deep rooted
religious hatred or ethnic tensions
in doing so we're going to contribute to
a very broad economics literature on
ethnic conflict and
interstate conflict but our goal with
this paper was also to
try to contribute to the ongoing policy
debate
on how the international community could
potentially
help prevent the military or
decentralize the military
from continue to engage in violent
second civilians
and perhaps how to inform the
humanitarian response
to address the psychological toll that
these refugees bring with them
the results that we're going to present
to you on our story
is structure around a three-prong
empirical approach
firstly we're gonna present you a set of
difference indifference regressions that
aren't going to help us establish
whether or not there were systematic
economic motivations
driving ethnic persecution in myanmar
and the hypothesis we're going to test
is that in periods when rice prices
are particularly high in regions that
are
more suitable for rice cultivation
conflict might increase
and if this is the case this is evidence
that there are systematic economic
motivations behind violence
the second part of the paper is going to
be based on
vector auto regressions or vars
this is a statistical framework that
allows us to document
how different actors involved in this
conflict
behave behave over time and how they
respond to one another's actions
and this is going to be very helpful for
us to compare
the way in which the military has
treated the rohingya
compared to other ethnic minorities and
lastly we're gonna present you a set of
very
basic yet hard to come bike summary
statistics
on the prevalence of depression and past
experiences with trauma
among refugees currently living in cox's
bazar
and this is to try to paint the enormous
human tone
of the ethnic persecution we're trying
to describe
and explain and we're going to start
with the first section the
rise differences in differences approach
here as
i was saying earlier the motivation or
the goal
is to understand whether
changes in international price of rice
could lead to an increase or a decrease
in conflict in areas that are
more suitable for land cultivation which
would then suggest
that ethnic violence is underlined by
economic motives
and our empirical analysis is going to
be based on a series of
stylized facts that make it particularly
suitable
for asking the question at hand the
first is that rice is the most
important staple food in myanmar it
accounts for over 40 percent of
agricultural production
and in particular most of the rice
cultivated in the country
is wetland rice which you can see
portrayed in the picture
on the bottom left of the slide
secondly myanmar is a price taker
on the international global market even
though it exports a very large fraction
of its domestic crop nearly 10 percent
the amount is still too small to affect
international rice prices
and therefore this is going to be a core
assumption
underlying our analysis myanmar is a
price taker and hence changes in
international prices
are going to be active as an exogenous
shock to domestic prices
the last stylized fact that underlines
our analysis and that is going to help
us
identify the causal effect of changes in
prices
is the fact that wetland rise has very
specific geoclimatic needs
if you look at a map of myanmar and even
within rakhine state what you're gonna
see
is that the suitability of different
regions growth within the country and
within the state
for growing rice is gonna vary widely
here what we present is an index of
suitability of different plots of land
both in myanmar hall and rakhine where
the rohingya live
and what this shows is that there is
a lot of variation in how suitable some
places are for growing rice relative to
others
and here we're gonna exploit a very rich
data set
coming from the fao the global
agroecological zone data set
that contains very fine granular
information
on how good a certain area is for
cultivating
and growing rice and the dimension
suitability is going to be composed by a
number of variables such as
precipitation temperature quality soil
etc
now our empirical strategy
is designed to test two potential
mechanisms through which
changes in rice prices could affect
conflict
the first is the so-called rapacity
effect
what this tells us is that if the price
of a commodity
goes up that means that the commodity
becomes more valuable
and therefore this creates incentives
for people to try to appropriate the
commodity
or even the inputs utilized to produce
that commodity
in our context that would be land so in
this case
a shock a positive shock to price to the
price of rice would increase
conflict in areas that are particularly
suitable
for growing rice but at the same time
rice is a very labor-intensive crop it
requires a lot of
manpower and a lot of human effort
and therefore it's possible that if the
price
of the commodity goes up the salary of
agricultural workers growing it
increases and this positive shock
to labor income acts as a disincentive
to engage in other economic activities
that may cause time
for instance engaging in appropriating
or looting rights
from someone else which might also have
some form of cost
some form of punishment so in this case
this is what we call
the opportunity cost mechanism in this
case
a positive shock to rice prices has a
pacifying effect
and what is interesting about analyzing
the effect
of shocks to rise prices
is that it could go either way it's
possible that
there is a rapacity effect in some
places and an opportunity cause in other
places and here is when it becomes
interesting that we're studying myanmar
myanmar is a setting where
one of the conflict actors has
a much stronger military capability
than all other actors that were studying
that any other
ethnic militia and therefore what we are
going to
argue is that in our setting these
forces might be particularly strong
especially in areas
that are highly suitable for line
cultivation and this
makes ideal our gifts in this set up
this is our baseline specification this
is the regression that we're gonna run
uh to begin with across the whole
country using conflict data from across
myanmar
our outcomes of interest are described
on the left-hand side the y's we're
gonna focus
on three subsets of conflict outcomes
the first is violent second civilians
perpetrated by any conflict actor in the
country
the second is a subset of of that
outcome violence against civilians
in this case perpetrated by state forces
and the last is gonna be
looting or property damage
and on the right-hand side of the
regression we're gonna have
an interaction term the first component
of which
is land suitability and this measure
summarizes
how good a certain township is
to grow rice so this is the average
quality or the average level of
suitability of
land in a certain township to cultivate
rice
and this is going to be multiplied by an
index
of rice prices and here what we do is
aggregating
rice prices for the three most commonly
grown
and sold types of rices domestically in
myanmar
on a certain month year so this would
not be the equivalent to thinking about
rice
or the average price of rice for
instance in january 2019
and therefore the coefficient of
interest and the one
which we're gonna show to you in in a
couple of slides
is beta the one that is gonna capture
whether
an increase in the price of rice is
going to lead to increased conflict in
areas that are more suitable
for land cultivation now we're going to
also add a vector of control variables
just to ensure that the fact that some
months are always different every year
and that some townships are
different um across the decade that we
observe
that these two effects don't bias or
estimates and we're also going to add
some controls for latitude
and longitude as well as a damage
variable to control for whether a
township is coastal
or not and lastly we are going to
instrument domestic prices using
international prices
and this is to address a potentially
important source of endogenous in our
setting which is
it's possible or we have reasons to
believe that the level of conflict
in a certain township could affect the
price of rice
domestically but we think it's highly
unlikely
that conflict in a certain township in
myanmar is going to have an effect on
international prices
and that's what makes this a very good
instrument
reassuringly we've tested for the
correlation between
these two variables it's very high so we
have a very strong first
stage and just to zoom
into how we want to interpret data
why beta is the coefficient of interest
this is because beta is
going to allow us to test our null
hypothesis
which is that economic forces do not
drive ethnic conflict in myanmar and
hence
both the magnitude and the significance
of beta
contain important information for us
it beta is very close to zero not
statistically significant different from
zero
then we would not be able to argue based
on our data
that there exists systematic economic
forces driving
violence behind the scenes however
if beta is different from zero
regardless of whether it's positive or
negative
we take that as of evidence that there
are economic motivations driving ethnic
violence in bala in myanmar
and in particular if beta is negative
what this tells us is that a positive
an increase in rice prices is going to
lead to a decrease in conflict in
areas that are more suitable for lung
cultivation therefore indicating that
there are economic forces driving ethnic
conflict and
that the opportunity cost mechanism
dominates
so the shock is specifying conversely if
data was positive
what this indicates is that in response
to
a positive shock to international prices
conflict
is higher in areas that are more
suitable for land cultivation
and what this means is that the capacity
mechanism
dominates so the bottom line before
jumping on the main results table
beta contains important information that
allows us to test our null
hypothesis and we're gonna just
dive into it here in this table
each of the columns represent
a regression and the bottom
raw indicates the outcome of interest of
each regression the
left hand side starting with column one
what this represents is a regression
of the number of incidents involving
violence
against civilians in a certain township
in a certain month and in column two
we're going to look at a slightly
different version of this variable which
is
the number of incidents of violent
second civilians in a township but we're
going to divide that
by the population size of that of that
township
in millions and this is to account for
uh the possibility that conflict
is not linear in population size
and lastly the third column in the third
column what we're gonna represent is a
binary variable that takes value one if
we observe
even only one instance of violent second
civilians
in a certain township month and zero
otherwise
and this is gonna help us address
concern over
concerns of our measurement error
sometimes
it's very hard to keep an accurate lock
of conflict
especially in myanmar a country where
there is no
free journalism and it's very hard to
report what's happening on the ground
so we might think that whether there
were three or four events
is not as important as whether there was
even one single event in a month and
this is why this binary variable might
bring additional information
so this is our beta this is the
coefficient of
interest and what we see is that across
the board
beta is positive and statistically
significantly
different from zero and if you remember
from
the previous slides what this means is
that
indeed ethnic conflict in myanmar is
underlined by
by economic motives and the rapacity
effect dominates
so increases in the price of rice
leads to increases in conflict in areas
that are more suitable
for rice cultivation and this is true
for the three
main types of conflict events that we
consider violence against civilians by
any force
violence against civilians by state
forces and looting
and property damage so this is for
the country as a whole but of course one
of the goals of the paper
is to explain what happens within
rakhine state what happens
in the land where the vast majority of
the rohingya live and see whether
these patterns apply in that setting as
well
so we reproduce the same regression the
same regressions but restricted
only to townships in rakhine state and
this is what we find
the caveat here is that the number of
observations
drops significantly and this makes us
look lose a statistical power
when looking at the entirety of myanmar
we had nearly 34 000 observations when
we restrict our analysis to rakhine
state we have
less than 1700 and despite this
what we have said is that beta again
is always positive the magnitude is very
similar
to that observed in the analysis at the
national level
and in some cases the coefficient is
even statistically significant
even though we've lost a lot of power by
restricting
our analysis to a narrow geographic area
so we take this as weak
evidence that the general pattern that
we've seen in myanmar
economic motives seem to be explaining
in part ethnic conflict seem to apply in
rakhine state
but there seems to be a lot that these
alone cannot explain
and this is what we're going to try to
tackle in the next section provide
a deeper look into why the rohingya
conflict might be different
and here we've done a bunch of robust
mistakes just to show you that
these results are not sensitive to small
variations in specifications
and we're happy to go over those perhaps
at the end of the presentation
in the interest of time now i want to
move into the second section that
in which we showed you vector auto
regressions just to remain
remind ourselves what what the purpose
of this part of the analysis was
var offers a statistical framework
that helps us understand and document
how different
conflict variables evolve over time
and how different conflict actors
respond to each other
the core assumption underlying this kind
of
analysis is that each conflict variable
say the behavior of the cat model the
response of the tatmudo
to an attack by an ethnic militia is
going to be a function of itself
and all other variables so this is to
say
how the tatmado decides to respond today
to an attack by an ethnic militia
is going to depend on the whole history
of behavior
of past behavior by the top model and
the behavior
observing the militia by the ethnic
militia in the past
we are also going to make some
additional but
fairly fairly reasonable assumptions to
shut down
reflection problems the way to think
about this
is uh akin to what happened when you
face a circular reference in excel when
the value of two cells that depend of
each other cannot be simultaneously
determined and you you get an error
message we're gonna make
just the minimum level of assumptions
necessary to prevent this from happening
in our case and here's how
we are going to interpret the vr
analysis
in our context we are going to show you
a series of graphs
that documents what happens on a day
when
an ethnic militia attacks how does that
ethnic militia behave
in subsequent days whether they keep
hitting or whether they retreat
completely
and how the that model responds over the
following
30 days and this is going to help us
establish
whether the tatmado treats different
ethnic minorities in exactly the same
way
or whether they treat perhaps the
rohingya differently
we want to be very upfront in that we're
not going to make a causal
interpretation for this finance we are
going to take
we're going to think about these graphs
as
uh provided an in-depth and useful uh
descriptive account of retaliation
patterns
but we cannot make a causal theme our
data doesn't allow us to establish
why ethnic militias may attack in the
first place
or why the top model might respond in a
certain way
what we see in this graph is that
following an attack on day one an attack
that is perpetrated
by a rohingya militia what we observe is
that on subsequent days there are no
follow-up attacks
so rohingya militias attack and then
they retreat
we observe that the level of conflict
goes back to baseline levels
almost immediately they don't engage
on additional conflicts and subsequent
days
now the graph on the right describes
the response of the tatmadon to that
precipitating event
that initial violent incident in which
the rohingya
militia is the perpetrator and what we
observe
is that on day one the attack model
responds
to one initial attack one conflict event
with 1.5 conflict events
and not only that what we see is that
the that model not only perpetrates
a counter attack which is 1.5 times as
powerful as the initial
incident that triggers conflict but they
hit back
one week later which almost the same
force so the tatmado does not respond
to violent incidents initiated by
rohingya militia
on a one-on-one basis but they respond
with disproportionate force
immediately and one week later and they
continue to
engage in smaller counter attacks
for a long period of time and we take
this
as evidence that the tatmado responds
very heavily to a violent incident
initiated
by the rohingya militia now
the question of interest here is
does this mean that the tatmado is
treating the rohingya
in a particularly harsh way or do they
systematically
respond to militia attacks regardless of
the ethnicity in a similar way
in the paper we look at how the cat
model responds to
the 10 most important ethnic militias
based on the number of conflict events
in which they were engaged over the past
decade and here
we're going to present you a comparative
analysis
of the two most important ethnic
militias
the first is the kachin understanding
how the tatmado treats the kachin
compared to the rohingya is important
because the kachin is a much more active
ethnic militia
they are engaged in a much larger number
of conflict incidents that
than the rohingya militia and they are
not
buddhists they are christians so one
might think that if the conflict is
partially underlined by religious hatred
being christian could be a potential
trigger for a disproportionate response
but that's not what we observe what we
observe is that
on a day when there is one violent
incident
in which the caching militia is the
perpetrator
the that model responds immediately but
responds
with the same amount of first responds
with exactly
one violent event one violent conflict
incident
and then we see that immediately after
both parties retreat
we don't see that the conflict escalates
we see that
for as long as we have data for for for
the following
few weeks the conflict goes back to
baseline level they respond to one
another
with proportionate force now what
happens with the rakhine
the ethnic kind is also
a good benchmark in this case because
they live in the same state
as the rohingya the difference between
the rakhine
and the rohingya is that the rakhine are
buddhists they
are not ethnically similar to the
majority burma in the country
but they are they are buddhists and what
we see is similar to what we observe
in the case of the kachin on days when
we observe
a violent incident in which the rakhine
militia is the perpetrator
we observe an immediate response by the
top model but their response with
proportionate force they respond
to one violent incident with one violent
incident
and following this bilateral clash both
parties seems to repeat the level of
conflict
falls very quickly back to baseline
levels the conflict does not escalate
so taking together what these findings
suggest
is that the way in which the tatmado
treats rohingya muslims is indeed very
different
to how they treat other ethnic
minorities
and this seems to be in sharp contrast
with
the argument employed by anzan zucci
that
the violence that we observe is not
systematic and it's driven by the whole
history of events between
the ethnic the rohingya malaysia and the
madonna
now so far our data and our
story has been silent on why the tatmado
is treating the rohingya in such a
different way
and here we cannot argue we have a good
answer
for this question but our data set
can't speak to one of the theories for
why this is happening that has gained
the most structure in recent years a
growing
number of scholars
both in south asia and uh based outside
of myanmar
have argued that the rise in buddhist
nationalism
in in anti-muslim sentiments in the
general population in myanmar
has allowed the tatmadon to
systematically
target and killing rohingya muslims with
impunity
and one story that seems to be supported
by
a number of qualitative studies and even
accounts by journalists in this field
is that a particular form of hated
speech
which is facebook's post facebook
post and nationwide protests organized
by
very highly respected buddhist monks
have helped spark spread rewards
about muslims have stroke fears
about a potential muslim invasion
and this has helped build a narrative
about how threatening rohingya muslims
are and this has not just justified
uh many instances of communal violence
but has helped
the military attack knowing
that there wouldn't be a domestic
backlash
what we don't know is whether it's true
that this
growth in hated speech and this growing
number of
anti-muslim protests that were organized
by
buddhist monks effectively
predict military intervention we don't
know whether
these interventions were followed by
a crackdown on muslim civilians and
this is exactly the hypothesis that our
data
allows us to test we have
a daily blog of protests
organized by buddhists by civilians both
in rakhine state and myanmar
and what we observe what the data tells
us is that
for every protest organized by buddhist
monks
in which they propagated rumors about
negative rumors about muslims or
they try to make a case that muslims
don't belong in myanmar
this protest was followed between
10 days and 20 days after by an increase
in the number of incidents
that are classified as violence against
rohingya civilians
and we're perpetrated by the top model
again we want to be very conscious here
in
describing these results we cannot claim
that anti-muslim monk protests are
causing
an increase in the number of violence
against civilian
incidents perpetrated by the top model
what we are
trying to suggest is that this evidence
seems consistent with the hypothesis
that there is an implicit coordination
between
some sections of the monastic order and
the military
and now i'm going to jump to the last
section of the analysis
the consequences of the crisis
understood as the
by this meaning the enormous mental
health hall
of ethnic violence on the survivor
and for this part of the analysis we are
going to use data from
the cox's bazar panel survey this is a
longitudinal study
that monitors living conditions and
physical and health outcomes
in cox's bazar this panel survey
is the result of a collaboration between
uh
well the co-authors of this paper and a
number of a number of researchers from
the gauge odi team and the world bank
we ran a baseline survey in april
between april and july 2019
and what we did was um serving
representatives of sample of refugee
and local hustles in cox's bazar
and asking them a series of questions to
assess
their experiences with trauma and their
mental health
and our instruments contain both close
and open-ended questions therefore
allowing us to look
deeper into the data or try to provide
an interpretation
for what the quantitative analysis was
telling us
and here is the first series of stylized
facts
what we found is that very large
proportions
of rohingya refugees regardless of the
year
in which they arrived in cox's bazar had
experienced
at least one trauma event here i want to
bring your attention to column 2.
what this tells us is that over 87
of all rohingya refugees who escaped the
2017 outbreak of violence
have experienced at least one trauma
event
and nearly one of three of these
refugees have experienced
more than five trauma events now
we have pointed here some of the most
commonly reported forms of trauma
they have experience in first person or
have weakness and when when you look at
the sample
size of the panel and the fraction of
refugees
who reports having survived near death
experiences
or torture or having witnessed the
murder
of a family member or a close friend it
becomes
increasingly difficult to believe the
narrative offered by the government that
these
were isolated events nearly 2 000 people
in our example report
having survived near-death experiences
now if you look at column three
this contains information about
the level of trauma to which previously
arrived rohingya refugees have been
exposed
and what we see is that those who arrive
even before
the most violent outbreak of violence
more than 83 percent also have re also
report
having survived at least one trauma
event so
even though that the fraction of
respondents reporting
each trauma event seems a little bit
lower in most cases the differences
is not significant what we find is
compelling
evidence that the violence the rohingya
has been exposed to
are not isolated events and it is highly
unlikely
that so many people have inaccurate
recollections
now before moving forward we wanted to
acknowledge the fact that initially got
us by surprise which is
very large numbers of bangladeshi
hosts also reported having
had experiences with trauma these are
qualitatively different these
in many instances these were cases of
domestic violence
but what we found was important to
communicate
is that the rohingya refugees is a
severely traumatized population
arriving in a host country where the
natives
have also been exposed to very
traumatizing experiences
and therefore might have psychological
needs and this is going to be important
for thinking about
how to design the humanitarian response
and this
speaks about how high priority
psychological support services might be
in this setting
and not just to refugees this is the
last
series of results we're going to present
to you today
unsurprisingly what we observe is that
rohingya refugees have very
high prevalence rates of depression if
we were to
aggregate across influxes and across
genders what we observe is that
one in three rohingya refugees meets the
symptom criteria
for depression the prevalence of
depression is also very high among
health
is one in four in this case meet the
symptom
criteria for depression and we are going
to show you
how this compares with other refugee
populations and the general population
in the us
and we're gonna we want to be clear here
that the goal of
this comparison is not to try to
minimize the experiences of refugees who
have been
resettled in other countries this is
just to qualify
our use of the word high rates of
depression when we mean that the rates
of depression in refugee camps are
alarmingly high this is what we mean
they are between twice and three times
as high as those among syrian refugees
who have been resettled in high-income
countries
survivors of the fukushima disaster and
four times as high
as the u.s general population
and now to conclude in this paper we
have shown you that
the persecution of ethnic minorities in
myanmar
has economic motives we have also shown
you that the persecution of rohingya
muslims
is very different or represent a very
different
retaliation pattern when you compare to
how the top model has treated other
ethnic minorities
and here we point out a potential reason
why the tatmadon has gotten away with it
which is there might be
an implicit coordination with ultra
nationalist buddhist monks
and lastly we have shown you that all of
this matters because the human
cost of ethnic violence is very large
both on the refugee population and on
the population
that they are hosting now we have two
highly vulnerable populations
living in a very small area and
competing for
psychological services that are
that are scarce and i think i'm gonna
conclude here
i promised teresa that i was gonna
finish a bit earlier to
leave room for questions and answer we
look forward to your
feedback comments and suggestions thank
you very much
so maybe elizabeth you wanna get started
i don't know teresa how do you wanna do
this
uh i would also like to invite my
co-authors to join the conversation and
answer directly
hi good afternoon everybody um uh thanks
very much um uh uh
a number of questions for you does
anybody
take seriously the burmese government's
narratives so it seems to me to have
that to be your overarching takeaway
seems you know a kind of
oddly weak conclusion of a lot of
careful inferential work now it may be
important to do that
for various policy reasons but it just
seems to me
that it kind of pulls the punch so to
speak
of what you are demonstrating
empirically
a second question is whether the var
graphs they don't seem to me to be
capturing
what on my read of some of the
international reports
is um an attack attacks
initially in 2016 then in august 2017
of by the arsa
followed by um a wave of ethnic
cleansing violence
that pushes the rohingya away
out imprisoned sums kills many and so on
and so that there's by kind of seeing
one event and then okay it's
disproportionate
in terms of the count and it's nice to
see a timeline
but that's not one counter capturing the
intensity of the violent which
is usually the way disproportionality is
measured
which we know in this case is huge
and also doesn't seem to capture that
the way in which these isolated attacks
were followed by these
waves of force displacement so
i'd like to understand more how you're
seeing
um how you're seeing those and
then a third question is can you
disaggregate between the economic
motives
so you you broke out property damage and
looting
uh but not by actor not by perpetrator
whether that's the tatmud
or presumably civilian members of
i don't know ethnic gangs or something
like that
but under the um
the rapacity you had two different
motives right one is
grabbing rice and the second is grabbing
land
and it would be you know just the
that would seem to be um really
important
to understand in terms of the durability
of displacement
of the rohingya so if you can speak to
that
that would be that would be very helpful
and then my last question is
a question not about the talk but about
the abstract which um
says that uh there's a line that says
that the uh tatmada use violence against
the rohingya to incapacitate the group
as opposed to merely deterring or
responding to attacks from muslims and
militias
and then you say later that and that you
showed
very nicely then you say the tatman dot
deliberately targets and kills rohingya
civilians but not civilians of
other minority groups you didn't show
that
and you know the record of human rights
violations in the north and northeast
um of the catching and the other ethnic
groups
um civilians of those ethnic groups is
is very long standing so
um i'm just wondering what your position
is on that
thanks very much thank you very much for
the excellent questions i'm going to try
to address all of them
thank you very much for the thankful
comments so i'm going to try to go in
all that
with regards to whether anyone takes
seriously the burmese claims
they do domestically and to the extent
that we believe that having the
endorsement
of voters and citizens have allowed them
to
continue these attacks and escalate over
time we thought
that it was important to confirm that
the international
narrative should be believed
domestically we understand you might
think it's very naive
that we think that this paper might
change the perception domestically
but we still felt it was important to
say now the comment is well
taken in the sense that given the
audience we have today perhaps that was
a point that did not need to be
emphasized
as opposed to others that would have
been a better ending so that is
that point is very well uh taken we're
also hoping perhaps this paper could
help
make a case in front of the
international court of justice
we think that that this quantitative
approach complements very well the
existing qualitative narratives
that have been easily disputed or
dismissed by the government of myanmar
so we're hoping maybe
that helps make this additional
contribution which is a policy oriented
one
yes now moving to the second question
you are absolutely right in that the
vars capture
responses on average over 10 years
and therefore the 2017 events are
highly diluted and there to some again
masked
here the goal of the vr was to show
that there has been a broader pattern of
systematic violence against muslim
before and after the outbreak of
violence because one of the claims that
we are hearing
about what motivates the uh this
conflict is that there are
sudden outbreaks of religious hatred and
then violence escalates and
retreats very quickly and we were trying
to offer
perhaps a longer term vision for what
happened
there is violence ongoing most of the
time even if that goes unnoticed
so the vr are portraying that average
level of conflict
over time and how the tatmado retaliates
or behaves
outside of major outbreaks of violence
but you're exactly right
the var don't speak to what happened
in 2017 that is that is exactly right
with regards to uh the third question
can we disaggregate between economic
motives this is an excellent point
unfortunately at the moment our data
does not allow us to distinguish between
uh
rise and land grabbing we fully
acknowledge that this
is a very important extension this is
something we're still working on
what we are gonna try to do to address
this concern that we're taking very
seriously
is look at the existing maps of what
happened to the land that has been
expropriated from the rohingya
using satellite data but this is an
ongoing process is
one that we expect is gonna take a few
more weeks
um so we don't have it today but it's a
work in progress
and then with regards to the comment
about the abstract
uh that line i think has been removed
we have now changed a little bit how we
explain um
our findings and we no longer refer
we no longer label the motives
of the tatmados incapacitation or
retaliation purely because we
acknowledge that
our data does not allow us to perfectly
answer
that question and then
embedded in question number four you're
absolutely right that our var
show an average number of
attacks on civilians of other ethnic
minorities that we're very much aware
exist and these are completely masked
because the levels like when you average
out over 10 years then
this seem to be much lower so this is
a clear drawback of using vars
uh at least 10 years of daily data to
portray or characterize
other ethnic conflicts we do show events
in which civilians have been targeted
and i guess that if we were to use a
slightly different unit or a different
definition
it would pop by the d civilians have
also been
attacked at the moment it doesn't
i need to think a little bit more about
how to combine var
with perhaps other ways of displaying
our results such that we
paint a better and more accurate picture
on what's happening in other states like
a team
so thank you very much for these
excellent comments i've taken notes
uh we're gonna be working on this over
the next coming weeks
oh i i think mushvik is uh also adding
some additional responses thank you
murphy
this is complementing what i just said
and do we have any more hands
i see hannah
have you found documented significant
improvement
that's a very good question i i wanna
answer please
uh let me know if i haven't addressed
any of the questions on the chat box
i wanted to answer to the question on
whether we have found or documented
empirical results on the con
the economic consequences of this ethnic
violence such as the
economic or employment laws uh
presumably among refugees
i would say we have some descriptive
statistics
but we are trying to work to produce
a a new set of preliminary results on
this topic we think it's very important
so i'm gonna respond on behalf of austin
who has been working a lot on this part
of the analysis
the short answer is we're working on it
and we will
eventually so i can uh i can just give
a little bit of detail on what we find
on the economic
side um so here you know the data
again are uh collected on the bangladesh
side of the border
after the displacement and and we
collected that you know and the
displacement occurred in 2017 july 2017
that's when the mass exodus of rohingya
uh
moved into bangladesh i should say the
latest exodus that they were
prior mass mass exodus
[Music]
and and so we have data we collected
data on
the economic situation of the rohingya
so let's say the camp population
that's one group a second group is
rohingya who were already present in
bangladesh prior to 2017
and then a third group is what we call
host communities so bangladeshis were
living near the camps
and then at the contrast we also have
bangladeshis living a little bit further
away from the camps
and so the comparison we can draw from
these data is how are the rohingya doing
relative to bangladeshis who live near
the camp
right so because the survey was
administered to both those groups
and the other thing we can do is uh
retrospectively ask okay
what are you doing right now what do you
have right now what is your employment
income assets right now
and what was it on like
uh say first quarter of 2017 before the
displacement
yeah and so the main one of the main
things that you learn
from the data are that like if you look
at the entire distribution of the
rohingya and let's look before 2017
before they were displaced
right they the entire distribution in
terms of income
uh assets right look uh
very similar to the distribution of
bangladeshis living on the other side of
the river
you know in kosovo district where the
where the camps are
right if anything the rohingya had
uh you know the population density on
that side of the border is lower so they
had
a bit more asset so a bit more land than
than bangladeshis did
say in february 2017 okay
and then what you observe right after
the displacement like the current
situation when we collected the data in
2019
is that the entire distribution of
assets etc shifts
sharply to the left for the rohingya
because they lost a lot
whereas uh in bangladesh it remains uh
similar
right and so what you learned from the
data is
one that like people were
like rohingya and bangladeshis living on
the side of the board near the camps
they were
under very similar comparable economic
situations were
doing similar things in agriculture
right and then the rohingya suddenly
lose all of their possessions and now
the distributions look very different
right so the the point of highlighting
this is one
you know you also we also have to
communicate with my
you know compatriots in bangladesh on
that
as as uh as attitudes towards rohingya
are changing over time have changed over
time as people have gotten
impatient right with you know a million
people
like uh living in camps and they're in
their midst
and people are perceiving a bunch of
different problems and
even though we had initially you know
welcomed them um and so
like to to document this to to show to
my bangladeshi comparators that
look these are people who are just very
similar to us they just it's just a bad
luck of being on the other side of the
river suddenly
they've lost a lot right and second is
something that we need to do a bit more
work on is like connecting
what we see in the loss of assets right
from pre to post 2017
right and and the consistency of the
reports that we're getting
in the bangladesh side of the border
with the looting result that paolo was
showing
on the myanmar side of border there is a
question on how we're planning to use
the satellite data i guess the answer is
we don't know yet because we're
still in the process of downloading it
and we
are waiting to see whether we're gonna
have whether
the quality of the image is gonna be
good enough for
us to be able to run a regression and
and look at
zooming and see what happens and see if
we find an overlap between
those areas and the areas from which our
respondents in our data set
come from so that's something that we're
looking forward to
have our hands on but we haven't quite
used yet
um and to add to paulo's point if i may
on susan's question about satellite data
one particular avenue as well that we
can pursue
and that we're hoping to is with
sufficiently fine-grained satellite data
especially
if we have time coverage after
the refugees have fled we can sort of
get an understanding
of what the land that has been
appropriated
from rohingya refugees um is now being
used for so for example is it now
land that's being rewilded has it been
recultivated
um and if it's been recultivated that
actually speaks to the potential
economic payoff
of displacing people from their land so
even if we can't use our
economist tool kits we might be able to
do some detective work
um to speak to the qualitative nature of
land use after departure
for me the i want to thank you for the
paper
um for me the value
of a quantitative paper
and the use of large uh data sets
um and remote sensing for that matter um
is that it knits together
qualitative information that we have
from
history's commentaries from on the
ground
right uh observations i'm thinking for
example of
a 20-year set of documents that the
korean human rights group
has been gathering right at the border
of every incident that has taken place
over the last two decades right
it's an unbelievably valuable source
it'll be interesting
to coordinate uh your observations with
that meticulous right um kind
of data that is available in an
archival sense um and so i'm
interested in there are two questions i
have
i'm interested in why you hit on the
price of rice
um i mean it's easily measurable right
it's available quite easily
what other economic variables
did you consider and reject
and why the qualitative information that
i have with respect to burma is that the
seizure of land
although occasionally it is for
irrigated rice land not just
rice land that's suitable but irrigated
rice land which is much more valuable
than rain fed rice um that most of the
seizures
and looting have been uh
for minerals right uh the effort to grab
land that can be used as plantations
the overtaking of businesses and
orchards and so on
and it at least in the qualitative
information that i'm familiar with
the idea of just seizing rice land or
looting rice
it appears almost not at all and if
you've got evidence
that this appears in the qualitative
data
as a motivation i would like to see
uh more of that the other problem i
suppose
is that you tend to treat the top medal
as a
unitary actor my understanding
is that the regional commanders
of the tatmud all and that was part of
the democratic opening
under things was to give them a free
hand to grab whatever they wanted
and to never bring any corruption
charges against them so we are dealing
as we can see on the streets of rangoon
in mandalay now
with individual police and army seizing
uh businesses looting and so on so
the the your your
question of response let's say
to the rohingya the arsa attack and so
on
uh there's a lot of your analysis that
treats the tatmudo as a unitary actor
and i think it is not correct to treat
uh chat as a unitary actor now that
changes your analysis i haven't quite
thought through the last thing is it
seems to me that
uh and this is um i don't want to make
this sound
um um dismissive because it's not
actually um but i'm wondering
how many people on your team uh um read
and speak burmese
all right and how much burmese sources
have played a role in what you've done
now there's a workaround for this
and and i would like to pose another
question then
there are lots of burmese intellectuals
uh and journalists who've spent
several decades uh working on the
tatmudo and trying to understand the
interior politics
of burma and you would be well served
uh people like minzin for one example uh
uh these are people who i think
if you have you run your analysis
uh by them and ask for
their comments um and criticisms
um and uh if you haven't
i think um it is professionally
a good thing for you to do i was just
going to say thanks thanks jim
would you be able to like if you send
once the paper is ready
uh so we're you know presenting
something that's a work in progress
so once it's ready would you be able to
uh connect us with the right groups who
should be
reading it maybe forward it to them and
oh you're on mute jim sorry
i'd be happy to okay excellent thank you
uh so i can actually thank you so much
for your questions jim
it's also personally very gratifying to
have you here because uh
you wrote one of my favorite books on
economic development uh seeing like a
state so it's an honor frankly
um so in terms of what other variables
we considered
we actually didn't run any statistical
inference on other variables but we did
it do the intellectual process of coming
to rice and in particular rain fred rice
so
that process actually involved
brainstorming other
agricultural commodities or mineral or
extract
active commodities that we could use a
similar type of approach
to um you know with the maps for example
and so
um one set of endowments that we did
consider
were oil gas and mineral resources
and after looking at the maps it just so
happened that the geographical spread of
those resources
was more concentrated
than the the rice gradient and it
ultimately just became quite a binary
variable
off of which frankly it was a
statistical feasibility issue
it just wasn't giving us enough
variation to speak
with our causal tools and of course you
know that's a limitation of our field
frankly
um and so we did actually consider this
idea about rain fed versus irrigated
rice and i think
we landed on rain-fed rice because it
seemed like
one of the most broad-based held
agricultural assets that
rohingya populations would you know have
access to
in the in the state however you bring up
a great point which
is that irrigated rice land may be more
of a target for expropriation
so we actually have data on that and we
could easily run
an additional statistical test using
rather than just
rain fed rice suitability we could look
at rice productivity
conditional on irrigation using a very
similar technique so
i think that's a fantastic suggestion
and it's implementable so
we'll go out and do it absolutely
thank you jay and i always also want to
thank james and i want to speak to the
second question
about whether we were aware that the top
model is not a unitary
actor i would say um i think as
economists we don't have the best
training on
uh qualitative work coming from south
asia but i read a few papers by means
seeing myself
and in fact the part of the var analysis
that focuses on the connection between
multinationalist monks hate speech and
military actions comes
from the paper by means saying title
anti-muslim violence in burma
why now so that actually mincing
inspired
a very important chunk of this paper in
his
in this particular article and i'm going
to refer to this because it's the one
i've read the most times but it's more
fresh
in my mind i think that he did not
dismiss the possibility or the argument
that the tad mado
is not a monolithic but he said despite
the fact that it's not a monolithic we
see systematic patterns that are
consistent with
what we have described in the paper now
i fully
acknowledge that we need to complement
this analysis
to capture in a much more accurate way
with the dynamics that you have
described yes there are some regional
dynamics at place yes
there are elements of the top model
response that are clearly
decided at a regional level and we
cannot at present fully account for that
now that you've brought it to my
attention very explicitly i'm going to
get back to the data i'm going to have
another look at the detail notes that of
describing the events that the outlet
data set collects
and i'm gonna try to think about how we
can address these comments
so i'm gonna need to think a little bit
more about it
and jim can you tell us i'm sure the the
entire audience would be
interested so what's your history with
the engagement in
in uh burma and uh when did you start
what type of work were you doing
oh that europe
um you forced me to tell you how old i
am
um uh i was in burma before any of you
were born i
i when i finished college for reasons
that
are um rather humorous
i had failed to go to work on my senior
economics
thesis at williams college and my
professor dismissed me because i hadn't
done enough work
in the fall semester i had fallen in
love um
and i had to have someone adopt me
if i wanted to graduate with honors in
economics
and i found a professor who was
interested in burmese economic
development
and uh he said if i work on burmese
economic development he would adopt me
and i said fine and as i closed the door
i asked myself
where's burma um i knew it was somewhere
out there between
india and thailand any case i wrote a
thesis
on burmese economic development in
particular the napoleon
uh nappin it was a it was a five-year
plan
um that burma was supposedly following
then
in any case i had a rotary fellowship
because
rather than going to law school and
spent a year in burma
felt completely in love with it and
would have done a dissertation on burma
had it not closed up and i ended up
working
in malaysia because the malay language
is spoken in four different southeast
asian countries
and i knew that at least one of them
would be open for field work
uh on the ground um and so
i'm i'm in a sense by accident a
southeast asianist and by accident uh
burma
specialist and i've kept up uh i've been
going back i'm
i'm working on an eco history of the
irawati river
and i hope to write a small book on the
irawati river
in which the life forms of the irrawaddy
river
play a bigger role than homo sapiens
that is i wanted to be a deep history of
the river
as a life world of of of um
of different life forms
very nice thank you sure
okay um so teresa should we call the
formal conference i mean seminar to a
close and
yes definitely yes we're on time so
thank you very much uh everyone for
attending and especially to paola and
her
cultures all of you for presenting your
results today
thanks a lot thank you for having us
thank you
you